good morning believe nation today's
message is keep challenging yourself
over to you Christopher Nolan do you
ever come up with ideas when you write
in the script they even scare you in
terms of not being able to pull it off
yeah I mean the really that's the
challenge of it as a writer I try and
take my directors hat off and not be
afraid and just say I want to write the
most exciting thing the most unexpected
thing I can think of for the story and
then I pick up the script again and put
the directors hat back on and go okay
how the hell am I going to do that and
that's when you know you're in a good
place because every film you want to be
challenging yourself you want to do
something different I think
entrepreneurs stop challenging
themselves I think when we start a
business there's a lot of challenge it's
a challenge in figuring out how we're
gonna make money in what product and
service we're going to be creating and
how we're gonna manage our schedule we
don't have a boss anymore telling us
what to do until this incredible freedom
to launch a company and a ton of
challenges to figure out and then once
we figure out those initial set of
challenges
I find that entrepreneurs stop
continuing to challenge themselves you
find something that you think is working
and you just then repeat that over and
over and over and over again just to
keep repeating the same thing constantly
and what ends up happening is you start
to get bored you start to get bored of
your business you feel boxed in but
nobody's put you in a box there's no
boss around you who put you in that box
you put yourself in a box the thing that
as entrepreneurs we hate being boxed in
and here you are putting yourself in a
box being bored doing the same thing
over and over and over again and one
things up happening to a lot of
entrepreneurs they don't realize that
they should have been changing a long
time ago and it said they think I'm
bored of this business I'm gonna I want
to move on and start something else and
then their business just plateaus like
you may have had some growth and it just
it stagnates because you're not
injecting anything new into it where the
key isn't necessarily just to drop the
business and move on to something else
it's that you need to constantly be
adding something
to challenge yourself in your business
on a regular basis like once you figure
something out
solve a new problem come up with a new
challenge right stretch yourself even
more what new product or what new serves
what new addition can you add to it how
can you better yourself as you grow and
evolve as a person you need to grow and
evolve your business and if you don't do
that your business will die and you will
die emotionally you will die you will
stop feeling the creativity and the love
and you'll start being negative and
people around you wonder what happened
to you and you see your business just
flatline this because you're not getting
joy from your company anymore and you're
not getting the growth from your company
anymore and that's on you if you go back
and look at my youtube channel from when
I started to where I am now and you look
at all of the changes that I brought to
the channel and then constantly bringing
to the channel that's part of what
drives me like if I had to just do the
same thing over and over and over and
over again I would get bored of it I
need to change and I inject my
creativity my love my spirit into each
video and into the new series that I try
out and thankfully you guys like them at
least most of them and that brings a lot
of joy to me as well but if I stop
experimenting if I stop trying to add
new things then I will start to lose
interest in this because entrepreneurs
you know we have entrepreneur EDD a lot
of us we'd like the new we like
searching for new things we like going
out and trying a bunch of stuff and so
when you're in a job it's easy to blame
the boss and it's easy to have timelines
and projects that you need to work on
because it's all been assigned to you
when you're in your own business you
need to challenge yourself constantly or
have a group of people around you who
force you to step outside your comfort
zone and find the next challenge as soon
as you start getting bored as soon as
you're not you know excited to go and do
the work that you're about to do if that
happens for too many days in a row you
know that you need to find a new
challenge to bring to door so the
question is today is I'm curious how do
you challenge yourself what do you do
leave in comments below I will join this
guy
thank you guys so much for watching have
an amazing day continue to believe and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso